children's programming is about to get a
lot more colorful with a reboot of the
iconic show reading rainbow this weekend
it's happening the classic children's
television series returns as an
interactive streaming program it's going
to be called reading rainbow live
first on cbs mornings we like when we
can say that our vlad dutier got an
opportunity to see how this icon of
television has been reimagined for a
brand new generation vlad good morning
take a look it's in a book
many of us tony can still sing the
reading rainbow theme song the program
was formative for so many kids more than
a decade after the original show went
off the air the children of those
children will get a chance to join in
and i got a behind-the-scenes look as
the cast and crew prepare for the
premiere
[Music]
it may look and sound a little different
but the message of reading rainbow live
is the same as the original
reading can take you anywhere and help
you be anything now we're in a clubhouse
with the rainbows and they're taking us
into their world
[Music]
young performers known as the rainbows
amy gulliamo is the creative director we
really wanted to make sure that we kids
could see themselves in their rainbows
representing their viewers is a
responsibility the rainbows including
kendall joseph isabella wager and eli
hamilton take to heart we have this
opportunity to give voices to
children and people of color i think
it's just so it's gorgeous no it's okay
i think i i really think it's so special
because
as a kid i was always wondering when am
i gonna see myself on television and now
i'm here giving that voice to other
people you know
i'm sorry oh my god i'm happy for you
but bella you're getting emotional
listening to them talking about it
what are you thinking about i think it's
been a long time coming for this you
know and i think it's time for
a lot of us to step back and give the
space to other people hi tani hi lavar
beginning in 1983 with beloved host
levar burton reading rainbow was a
fixture in households and classrooms
across the united states for more than
two decades hi boys and girls it was
created to address what was known as the
summer loss phenomenon the idea that
kids lose some of their reading
abilities during the summer break from
school
max my favorite thing to read is music
this new iteration addresses loss of a
different kind the call to action was
the pandemic executive producer stephen
beer took the idea to nancy hammon who
oversees the reading rainbow brand
there's no magic book that tells you how
we should act
during a pandemic and it just felt like
bringing something as simple and basic
like
books and music and and dance and
adventures was just a great escape so
simple
but really so important at this
particular time
[Music]
the new program won't air on pbs like
its predecessor but its format will be
familiar to the remote learning
generation viewers can watch reading
rainbow live online it's created to not
be a passive activity where kids are
just watching something on a screen it's
active after the kids view the event
they're going to be singing those songs
because it's going to stick with them so
we're not going to do the music
director
brought that vision to life you know
when i walked in here i was like i want
to go there i want to go over here i
want to play with that guitar i want to
ride that surfboard
yeah that's kind of the idea is to
create a space that's like homey and
genuine and earnest so that the viewers
of this show just want to participate
and be part of it and part of the
clubhouse even before i saw the
clubhouse i wanted to participate
they're going to have a rotating cast of
hosts but they are still looking for
some more so
i raised my hand too i was like me the
team took notice and invited me to
appear as a special guest and this is
the book that i am sharing today it's a
responsibility i take to heart too
to know that you're going to be part of
the
education
of young people what goes through your
mind when you think about that i feel
like our imagination is like our
greatest superpower when we think about
it and books are like food for your
imagination reading books when i was
younger it really helped me to like
dream
and believe that i could be anything
that i wanted to be you know one of my
goals with the show is to
give that message to the younger
generation you know
reading rainbow live from your sunday at
12 30 pm eastern online and of course
reading rainbow sent us
a little bit of swag to celebrate the
returns of this love children's show you
got some books i like what that guy just
said to you though
books are food for your imagination and
imagination is our superpower kendall
jones i love that he's from trinidad and
tobago and one of the things that i
thought was really remarkable is he told
me that uh
the fact that he's a child born in the
caribbean other children like him
like me i wasn't born in the caribbean
but my parents were yeah yeah would see
themselves represented on television and
be inspired by that that's what all of
the rainbows say yeah the glasses are
working for both of you like any glasses
here we go this is a very good
dale you make a great point you know
this show has fed many young minds so i
mean this show coming back it just
touches my soul
remember that for young children every
child that i've ever interviewed about
books says they say to me when i open a
book i can be anything i can go anywhere
and i can do anything and that's what
books do that's what they did for me
that's why i was so excited that they
asked me to be on it and to review one
of the books and so i'm so excited for
the return i was glad they were watching
and saw them i know they were they were
watching they saw us reacting highly
sought after this conversation for four
people wearing colorful glasses
tony they look good on you man they look
great on you are honorary rainbows and
i'm a big fan of the books all morning
about the books line you want to sing
take a
it's in a book reading rainbow
glad thank you so much